now I have a bit of a past history of
doing doc Matta so choose and
Astrophysical and cosmological datasets
and finding signals which initially look
like there might be a signal of DOC
metaphysics but turn out to be telling
us something very interesting about the
astrophysics about galaxies then people
have asked me well are you disappointed
that you didn't find dark matter in this
such I guess I feel that whenever you
learn something like this the universe
is telling you something amazing about
itself you've just learned something
that nobody in the world has ever
understood before and in those
circumstances it feels a little bit
ungrateful to complain that no the
really cool thing I just learned was not
the cool thing that I wanted to learn
it's something else
so you know of course I'd be happy if we
discovered dark matter but if we just
keep doing better and better Dark Matter
searches and we keep learning more and
more about the fascinating history about
galaxies and the astrophysics of our
galaxy and our local cosmos I'll be okay
with that